so I'm sitting there just kicking back
doing nothing and this little guy comes
in and comes up to me and he says uh
could I could I go through your records
please and I I said sure of course you
can I want to guess this one and he he
looks through his the records and I said
you know I I have the new victory album
they they didn't mail it to me he goes
you do could you could you could you put
it on cuz we're getting ready for the
tour and so I said anything that you
want to hear and he goes yeah shake
shake your body down to the ground he
said I'm getting the dance dance routine
down so he gets out and he start I put
it on and he starts dancing to it and
I'm like wow and he he goes can you play
it again I said yeah and he goes do you
have a cassette player and I said I I do
absolutely I'm not I can't do an
impression of him so I'm not going to
try and I said absolutely and he goes I
I just came from the studio with Quincy
so I got not Michael Jackson Michael
Jackson and he goes out to his limo and
he he comes in with a cassette and he
goes we just put this together today and
so I I play it for him and he stop stop
stop he goes play that part again I go
okay and he goes stop stop stop can can
you play it again and then when I point
to you turn it up loud I said okay so I
play it again Turn It Up loud and he
goes horns aren't loud enough horns
aren't loud enough on that I got to tell
Quincy the horns aren't loud enough and
so I'm listening and he's playing I'm
playing rock rock with you or I can't
remember which one Don't Stop Till You
Get Enough from his uh album H but he
was just on top of the music he was
listening to every single he obsessed
yeah he but but focused he wasn't one of
these artists that let any other people
do it for him and then he would get out
there and dance to this song and I'm
like wow you know cuz I grew up the
Jackson 5 and he wasn't Michael Jackson
at the time he was just a member of The
Jackson 5 and I this was a band that had
saved my ass so many times when I was
DJing you know put on Dancing Machine
pack the floor you know and uh one bad
you know One Bad Apple don't spoil the
whole bunch girl and all this kind of
stuff and ABC I loved all that music and
then um afterwards he took my card and
he said would you do some parties for me
and I said sure So I go to his house on
Haven Hurst in Nino I've been there yeah
yeah and I I djed about 12 parties for
Michael Jackson did he pay well he paid
well and then I I did the launch party
for the tour and I had to be screened by
the FBI so I'm glad I had a green card
at the time because uh the Jackson 5 and
myself were and it was the Jacksons but
they did the S like a five because they
left mown and gone to Epic uh we were
all in the um bank vault of this bank
that was on Wilshire Boulevard and now
it's like a clothing store you s laon
but right across from the Beverly W
Hotel and the idea was we were in the
bank vault and they were breaking out of
the bank vault and they had
Entertainment Tonight there and all the
TV cameras and then I had my fog machine
so they of course you did yeah and they
they tried to put give us a
walkie-talkie but the vault door was too
thick for the radio signals but the they
weren't locking the door so it was
opened slightly so we had an XLR cable
go through and when they gave me the
signal it was 30 seconds before they
would open the vault door and that's
when I dropped the dry ice into the fog
machine fill the thing with fog turn my
one laser on back then it was just a red
dot just like you know like pong back in
the early days going up and down it was
just a red laser going through the and
they opened the thing and the fog came
out and the Jackson came dancing through
it on